KNOW IF THERE’S ANYTHING TO
BRING YOU IN ANY DEVELOPMENTS TO
REPORT.
LET’S GET BACK TO THE SHOW, WE
SAID EARLIER TODAY IF YOUR
SCHOOL IS NOT OPENING, DO NOT
ACCEPT IT, IT IS YOUR CHILD,
YOUR MONEY.
WHY SHOULD YOU PAY FOR SERVICE
YOU ARE NOT GETTING.
REOPEN SCHOOLS OR GIVE ME MY
SCHOOL MONEY BACK.
WE SAID, YOU SHOULD TAKE IT TO
THE COURTS AND FIGHT FOR YOUR
RIGHT IN YOUR MONEY.
TO EXPLAIN HOW THAT COULD WORK I
AM JOINED BY MEMBER PRESIDENT
TRUMP’S OUTSIDE LEGAL TEAM AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
AMERICAN CENTER FOR LAW AND
JUSTICE JORDAN SECULAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
YOU WERE THE FIRST THAT I
THOUGHT OF TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
I GUESS YOU HAVE BEEN IN THE
NEWS AND WE ALL KNOW WHAT IS
BEEN GOING ON LATELY WITH
RESPECT TO THE PRESIDENTS LEGAL
TROUBLES AND SO ON.
BACK TO AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
WORK IS SUPPORTING THESE LEGAL
CASES THAT REALLY DRIVE FORWARD
THE PRINCIPLE OF FREEDOM AND THE
FREEDOM OF PARENTS TO CHOOSE THE
BEST SCHOOL FOR THE CHILD
ESPECIALLY OF THE SCHOOL IS
OFFERING IT.
>> SCHOOL CHOICE HAS BEEN AN
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE KEYED IN ON
AND WE ARGUED TO THE SUPREME
COURT FOR DECADES, NOT JUST ONE
DECADE BY DECADES AND NOW WE ARE
SEEING REAL RESULTS WHEN IT
COMES TO SCHOOL CHOICE, THOSE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE IN PLACE
THAT PREVENTED RELIGIOUS SCHOOLS
FROM RECEIVING VOUCHER MONEY,
THAT WAS JUST STRUCK DOWN BY THE
SUPREME COURT, ALL THE
AMENDMENTS THAT CAME ABOUT IN
THE COUNTRY WHEN THERE WAS IRISH
IMMIGRANTS IN IRISH CATHOLIC
IMMIGRANTS, IT DOES NOT SEEM IN
2020 AND THEN WE HAVE LAWS ON
THE BOOKS AND THAT MANY STATES
OF 40 PLUS STATES SAYING WE WILL
NOT GIVE MONEY TO RELIGIOUS
SCHOOLS EVEN IF WE DO HAVE
VOUCHER PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE
DON’T LIKE CATHOLICS, THAT’S HOW
THAT LAW STARTED IN 1875 IN
BASICALLY SHUT DOWN BY THE
SUPREME COURT THIS TERM IN A
CASE THE ESPINOZA CASE OUT OF
MONTANA.
THAT IS GREAT NEWS, BUT YOU
POINT TO THE SECOND ISSUE, IT IS
GREAT TO HAVE SCHOOL CHOICE,
GREAT TO HAVE DOCTORS IF THERE
IS SCHOOL, IF THERE IS SCHOOL.
WHAT WE ARE LOOKING AT NOW, WHAT
HAPPENS FOR THE UNDERPRIVILEGED
KIDS, THE SAME ONE WE ARE
WORKING WITH WHY WE WANT
DOCTORS, WE BELIEVE THEY ARE THE
BEST OPTION, TAX CREDIT IS GREAT
AND WONDERFUL AND A LOT OF THEM
ARE MOST UNDERPRIVILEGED AND NOT
PAYING TAXES AND THEY DON’T
COVER ENOUGH.
SOMETIMES THEY ARE $500 OR
THOUSAND DOLLARS, THEY DO NOT
COVER THE TUITION.
WE ARE LOOKING AT VOUCHER
PROGRAMS, YOU KEYED ON SOMETHING
IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US WITH
CHILDREN.
IS SCHOOL COMING BACK, I GET A
DIFFERENT E-MAIL EVERY FEW DAYS
FROM THE SCHOOL, I AM NOT SURE,
IT MAKES ME NERVOUS.
I’M IN A SITUATION WHERE I CAN
FIGURE SOMETHING OUT, MOST
PEOPLE ARE NOT.
STEVE: LET’S LOOK AHEAD, I WANT
TO GIVE YOU VERY SPECIFIC
SITUATION, LET’S SAY THERE IS A
PARENT WATCHING TONIGHT AND THEY
SAID I AM NOT KIDDING THE
ANSWERS I WANT FOR MY SCHOOL OR
MY SCHOOL BOARD, I’VE HAD
ENOUGH, I WANT TO SUE AND TAKE
THEM TO COURT TO GIVE ME THE
MONEY LIKE A VOUCHER SO I CAN
SPEND SOMEWHERE ELSE.
COULD YOU HELP THEM WITH THE
LEGAL REMEDY?
JORDAN: YES, IF IT LOOKS LIKE IN
THEIR DISTRICT ALREADY THAT
THERE IS NOT GOING TO BE SCHOOL
AND SOME ALREADY ANNOUNCED THAT
OR THE SCHOOL WILL NOT BE
ADEQUATE FOR THEIR CHILD, AT THE
AMERICAN CENTER FOR LAW AND
JUSTICE, THIS IS SEPARATE FROM
OUR WORK FOR ATTORNEYS FOR THE
PRESIDENT, AT THE ACL J WE DO
NOT CHARGE OUR CLIENTS, IF YOU
GO TO ACL J.ORG YOU WILL BE
CONTACTED BY OUR SENIOR
ATTORNEY, THAT DOES NOT COST YOU
ANYTHING, IF WE DECIDE YOU HAVE
CASE THAT WE CAN GO FORWARD IT
WILL NOT COST YOU ANYTHING, WE
WILL FIGHT THE BATTLE FOR YOU
AND I THINK YOU KEYED ON ON A
NEW BATTLE, I HOPE WE CAN
PARTNER, YOU, ME AND GROUPS LIKE
US WHO CAN REPRESENT THESE FOLKS
WHO HAVE NOT HAD THE MEMES TO
HIRE BIG LAW FIRMS, WE REPRESENT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, WE CAN TAKE THE LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO COURT OR
STATE TO COURT.
DON’T WORRY ABOUT THAT, PEOPLE,
WE CANNOT DO IT WITHOUT CLIENTS.
PEOPLE HAVE TO GO TO ACLJ.ORG
AND TELL US WHAT THEIR SITUATION
IS AND WE CAN GOING FIGHT FOR
THEM.
STEVE: BRILLIANT, I KNEW YOU
WERE THE PERFECT PERSON.
I AM SO EXCITED LISTENING TO
YOU, THANK YOU FOR EXPLAINING
THAT SO CLEARLY.
I REALLY WANT TO ENCOURAGE
ANYONE WATCHING, WHETHER YOU ARE
A PARENT, YOUR GRANDPARENT AND